When I just mentioned things like,
you know,
the greatest advancements in medicine,
technology,
science,
um,
basically human civilization has
complimented particularly white men.
Uh,
I'm actually called a bigot and
a Nazi and all sorts of things.
So I wonder if these
words now outright this,
that have no power and they're just
used against anyone who doesn't tow the
party line.
Yeah,
well they're definitely,
while in the thing
about a thing about the,
the,
let's say the disproportionate
contribution of European,
a small number of European
men over the last 600 years,
something like that.
Maybe you could go all the way back to
the Greeks if you're willing to call them
European,
which,
you know,
perhaps you could get away with.
Um,
it's a,
it's a drop in the ocean
by historical standards.
And of course now that the entire
world is linked together by,
by electronic communication and education
is available to far more people,
you see that,
um,
contributions to the world's knowledge
are being made at an incredible rate by
people all over the world.
And so now again,
it's a historical accident in some ways,
not precisely an accident,
but as historical accident.
Let's use that term that some of these
technologies for learning and discovery
happened to be established in Europe and,
and that gave Europeans of technological
advantage and also the opportunity to
contribute in a major
way to new disciplines.
But that's being distributed.
Yeah.
Especially if you think origins,
like we have to give
credit where credit's due,
like the Aba Aviation,
automobile,
uh,
many of the diseases cures like the origin
really did come from Mensa matter how
much feminist rant and rave.
There is just no denying this,
that human societies have
advanced tremendously because
of these achievements.
Yeah,
there is no doubt about that.
And then it's,
yeah.
And that it's a relatively small number
of people who've contributed immensely.
Well,
you see the same thing now you see the
same thing now that there's a handful of
remarkable inventors that,
that are literally changing
the world in front of our eyes.
And it is the case that it's often a very
small number of people who change the
world in that manner.
So
look at Mark Zuckerberg.
I mean,
I was reading like Facebook
is used by a billion people,
uh,
like a day,
or I don't know if it was a day or,
it's crazy number of people.
Astonishing.
Yeah.